so i thought one thing that'd be
interesting to talk about is wi-fi's
hidden node problem and this applies to
any sort of wireless networks but it's a
it's an interesting thing that appears
when you start using wireless networks
to communicate
so let's start with a little diagram and
we'll build this up as we're going
typical wireless network we have a
access point which will represent as an
aerial and then we'll have our laptop or
something that we want to connect to it
so they can communicate via
wireless networking so it sends a signal
over a radio wave on a particular
frequency to the access point and the
access point can send one back
on the same frequency wi-fi uses the
same frequency to transmit and send so
this machine is able to detect if
anything else is sending on the network
as well now as we all know because we've
all fallen found of this is that we walk
too far away from the access point and
we suddenly lose signal
there is a range on wi-fi as we move
further away the signal drops off the
intensity drops the signal strength
drops and eventually it goes off a cliff
and you lose connectivity now why is
that a problem well the problem we've
got is if we've got more than one node
in our network let's just draw another
person using a laptop or some device
here
then if they both try to transmit at the
same time so let's call this machine a
and let's call that one machine b if
machine a tries to transmit that's fine
it can use the shared medium the shared
radio space to transmit
and machine b could transmit at a
different point it can use the same
shared radio space to transmit and the
data gets transmitted and received by
the access point no problem but if these
were to try to transmit
at the same time
then they would both use the same radio
space and the signals would interact
with each other interfere with each
other they'd corrupt each other and so
at the access point there'd be garbage
received and the data wouldn't be
transmitted so the way that wi-fi is
designed it borrows from ethernet and
quite a lot but the way it's designed is
it before it transmits a device will
listen on the network because it can
receive on the same frequency unlike
when we looked at aloha wi-fi
transmission receives on the same
frequency so we can hear what other
devices are doing it'll listen on the
network and ask the question is there
anything being transmitted if there's
something being transmitted then it
thinks well okay if i transmit now it's
going to corrupt that my data is not
going to get through the other person's
state it's not going to get through what
it does is it waits for a certain amount
of time
and then after that certain amount of
time we should pick a random delay it
will then transmit its data if the
network is saying clear if the wireless
frequency is then clear at that point so
if you've got multiple nodes in there
it's not a problem because they can
cooperate before any node sends it will
listen to the wireless space and if it's
empty of signals there's no carrier then
it will transmit this is what we call
carrier sense with multiple access it's
used on wi-fi it's used on ethernet and
things it's the idea that before you're
transmitting something you listen to
check that there's no carrier present
before you send it because otherwise
it's just gonna corrupt it which is
quite how we do human speech yeah
absolutely i waited till the break then
before i said that yeah exactly that's a
really good analogy um we've all sort of
been in situations where if you wanna
have a good conversation one person's
talking then when they stop you start
and things you don't start talking while
someone else is talking otherwise it
ends up as an intelligence you can't
tell what exactly is it's happening now
exactly exactly now the thing we have to
remember is that
each of these machines there's a range
that the signal will go we said that at
the beginning as you move away from the
wireless access point signal drops off
and so on so let's just draw a circle
this is an arbitrary size circle it's
not going to be a circle
and there's going to be a similar one
for this machine which is probably going
to do something like let's label this
this is the one for machine b and this
is the one for machine a now
both of these circles they go on bigger
in the other side as well machine a and
machine b are in those things
so they can hear when the other one
transmits not a problem let's suppose we
have a third machine though let's call
it machine c
and it's right down here we'll call that
machine see can you see that on the
other camera yes you can
hi
and let's suppose though that its
transmission circle the range it can get
sort of just that now it can transmit
perfectly fine to the access point and
it can receive data a can transmit to
the access point it can receive data b
can transmit to the access point but the
key problem we've got here
is that machine c is out of range of
both machine a and b
so we could get the problem
where machine a decides if the network's
clear because he can't hear anything on
there he can't sense anything on the
wireless frequencies and machine c does
exactly the same thing it can't sense
anything on the wireless frequencies and
they both try and transmit at the same
time and what's actually received by
the access point
is just corrupted data neither packet
got through this is what we call the
hidden node problem because there's
another node that this machine is not
aware of that can transmit and vice
versus another there's nodes that this
machine is not aware of that can
transmit but the actual thing they're
transmitting to can hear both of them
because it's sitting in this gap in the
middle where it can hear
all of them and so we need to have some
way
that we can
organize these machines so that when
they transmit they do so in a way so
that the access point doesn't get
corrupted data even though machine a and
c can't see or hear each other they
can't pick up each other's transmissions
now you've got a similar problem on the
original ethernet back when you had a
shared physical piece of wire for each
machine on ethernet they were all
connected to that
you had exactly the same problem and
they used the same idea of carrier sense
with multiple access in that they would
wait until the network was clear
but they could detect because the signal
was on a piece of why it didn't drop off
in the same way they could detect if
another machine transmitted at the same
time and so they could detect the
collision stop transmitting wait a
random amount of time and then
re-transmit and as long as the random
amount of times were different one of
them would be able to transmit and the
other would get it through
you can't do that on wi-fi because it
can't detect the carrier from this
machine and vice versa this can't detect
the carrier from that machine so we need
to take a different approach so on
ethernet they use the system called csma
carrier sense multiple access with
collision detection we should probably
do a computer file on that at some point
that was the original ether these days
when it switched and things that
problems disappeared but that's another
computer file that someone needs to do
at some point
can't do that with
wi-fi so we need a different approach
and the approach we use is carrier sense
multiple access
with collision avoidance so we use this
sort of this approach instead so with
ethernet you detect the collision and
recover from it
with wi-fi you try and stop the
collision happening in the first place
so you do something with the three
machines and the access point you've got
here to stop the collision in the first
place let's think about the problem
we've got we've got a problem where
machine a and machine c are transmitting
at the same time the data's interfering
with each other we need something to try
and stop them transmitting at the same
time so what we want
is a mechanism where one of the machines
let's use machine as an example can
reserve the radio space while it sends a
packet so he wants some way of reserving
it so all the other machines know don't
send anything at this point
and so the way that we do this in wi-fi
is we send out what's called a request
to send or rts
message from
the machine that's trying to send to the
access point so this sends out a request
to send message and this message is
designed to be very very short
the idea being that it's very very short
it's very unlikely to collide with
anything
and so we send a message out from
machine a that's very very small it's
received by the access point it's not
received by machine c
but it's received by the access point
and
it gets that request to send and then it
sends back what's called a clear to send
packet
with details of which machine is clear
to send and it sends that out
over the wi-fi network and the beautiful
thing about that is that when the clear
to send messages sent out it'll go out
to all the machines will also be picked
up by machine c
even though it's not in range of a and b
and so didn't get the request to send
packet it will still see the clear to
send and so it knows at that point that
hang on something's about to transmit on
this network okay i was about to send
something but i know it's been reserved
for another machine i'll wait some
specified period of time before i send
out my request to send
to the access point and sort of get the
permission to
use the shared radio space to send my
messages so what we do with collision
avoidance which stop the collision
happening in the first place by getting
each of the machines to reserve the
radio space before they send their data
you might think what happens if machine
a and c both send a request to send at
the same time
well that's not a problem because if
they both end at the same time
then it'll either get corrupted
in which case the access point doesn't
receive it and doesn't send out the
clear to send so neither of them receive
the clear to send so never send out
their data they'll just delay for some
period of time and then try to send out
the request to send again
or one of these will get through
fractionally before the other
and when they receive the clear to send
the other machine will see that it's not
for them that they've received that
clear to send so they don't send anyway
so and then they can send the request to
send anyway so this approach of just
sending out a very small package
means that it's very unlikely to collide
anyway because it's so short and so the
chances of two machines in that very
small time period transmitting at the
same time becomes very very small if
you're sending out a 1500 byte packet
much more chance of that colliding with
something else i mean if you think about
it if you're sending out 1500 bytes
that'll take a certain amount of time
and you're sending out another 1500
baht's that only has to sort of move
back one byte of overlap when you've
corrupted both packets
even though most of them have actually
got transmitted without any problem if
you're sending sort of a very small
64 or less whatever size it is packet
then the chances of them overlapping are
far less example of this if you've ever
seen a very big
heavy goods vehicle going down the road
what you'll often see first is that they
don't just send that
down in one go and sort of try and force
it through waiting for the other bits of
the traffic to get off the road you
often see there's police dispatch riders
and things that go ahead of it which
sort of clear the road first so that the
heavy goods vehicle could go through
and things exactly the same thing here
we're sending out the request to send
which clears the way and then the big
packet that we want to transmit goes
through after it the only slight change
from that that those actually does i
think in wi-fi is that if the data
you're sending is very very small
then it's sort of bundled in with the
request to send because
otherwise it ends up using more
bandwidth than you need to the chances
are that the data will get there and
again you're going to send out another
request to send if you don't get it so
if the date is very very small you can
still send it out and sort of optimize
things a bit there so that's the hidden
node problem and the way that we use
carrier sense multiple access with
collision avoidance to solve it on wi-fi
uh over and out
yep over and out
so you should never say over and out
it's just out
is it yeah because as soon as you say
overly saying i'm not going to talk
anymore so if you say over and out
you're the first ever is sort of broken
i think so just out okay i've never used
cb radio but i have heard that but it is
literally that's that's another shared
medium isn't it yeah exactly sort of
exactly you need some kind of protocol
you need a protocol to sort of use this
at the same time and things so yeah it's
good analogy out out
if we just scroll forward in time we can
see that as things start to happen we
get to this point where
everything starts to reroute and rather
than going directly to facebook you can
start to see
w this is some actual cypher text that
we'll be breaking later does it honestly
start with zoos as in conrad's views
yeah the reality of random yeah